Hallo ihr Lieben!
Oder sollte ich heute viel lieber sagen: Merhaba, hoş gelidniz?
Heute gibt's türkische Rezepte bzw. türkische Dips.
Man nennt sie auch Meze. Also Meze, das sind immer so Kleinigkeiten,
die man dann vor dem Essen oder während des Essens serviert
in die man dann so dippt oder mal hier und da was Kleines isst.
(H: Also Vorspeisen!)
Vorspeisen, genau!
Und heute gibt's eben 3 Dips.
Bei dem einen bin ich mir nicht sicher, ob es auch so ein bisschen arabisch angehaucht ist
aber jetzt kommt erstmal ein typisch türkischer Dip!
Nämlich ein Möhren-Joghurt Dip.
Yoğurtlu Havuç Ezmesi heißt das auf Türkisch und wir fangen jetzt an.
Ich habe jetzt hier Möhren geraspelt ganz einfach und habe hier auch in meiner großen beschichteten Pfanne
auch schon ein bisschen Öl. Ich schreibe euch natürlich alle ganz genauen Mengenangaben
unten in die Videobeschreibung und da schreibe ich euch auch rein, für wie viele Portionen das reicht.
Ich mache jetzt hier übrigens die doppelte Menge
weil Hamza und ich bekommen jetzt die
nächsten zwei Tage Besuch.
So, die Möhren habe ich jetzt ungefähr 5min lang gedünstet.
Ihr müsst jetzt nicht die höchste Stufe nehmen, ich hab Stufe 6 von 9 genommen.
Lasst das kurz ausdampfen, so circa 15min.
Aber in der Zwischenzeit kümmere ich mich um den Joghurt.
Jetzt nimmt man hier einen sehr fettigen Joghurt, also einen 10%igen am besten.
Und da gebe ich jetzt Dill, Salz und Zucker mit dazu und presse dann noch Knoblauchzehen mit rein.
Und im Anschluss nur noch die Möhren unterrühren und fertig ist unser erstes Meze!
Ich find's sehr sehr lecker, ich mag das total gerne. Und ihr könnt das jetzt ziehen lassen, 1h im Kühlschrank
oder auch über Nacht oder gar nicht! Aber ein bisschen ziehen lassen finde ich schon immer ganz gut.
Und dann hält der Dip sich auch mindestens 2 Tage lang.
So und jetzt machen wir den nächsten Dip und das wird sein: Acılı Ezme. Bis gleich!
So, für Acılı Ezme benötigen wir Paprika in Rot und Grün und Chili.
Und ich werde euch auch hier natürlich die ganz genauen Mengenangaben
hier unten in die Videobeschreibung schreiben. Und das ist ein scharfer Dip.
Acılı Ezme heißt ja auch auf Deutsch übersetzt scharfes... Zerstampftes?
(H: Acılı heißt scharf, ne?)
Acı heißt scharf, genau.
Und eigentlich ist das Rezept echt mega einfach: ihr tut jetzt alles in einen Mixer,
ihr könntet auch jetzt z.B. ein Wiegemesser nehmen und alles so fein hacken, das geht auch,
aber so geht es ein bisschen schneller. So und jetzt gebe ich hier noch gehäutete Tomaten rein.
Alles rein, das ist so easy! Hier habe ich noch Granatapfelsirup, ich liebe Granatapfelsirup!
Einfach rein, schön ausschaben dass wir auch nichts verschwenden.
(H: Jaa?)
Pause machen. Pause.
Mach 'ne Pause!
(H: So, jetzt haben wir Pause gemacht!)
So und - genau! Jetzt kommen noch rote Zwiebeln mit dazu ...so.
Ein bisschen Olivenöl, nehmt da bitte gutes Olivenöl, schön kalt gepresst. So!
Natürlich Salz und Pfeffer. Ihr könnt natürlich auch später noch nachsalzen, ne?
Aber ich schreibe euch das ganz genau in die Videobeschreibung.
Dann habe ich hier noch ein bisschen Tomatenmark  und dann fehlen uns nur noch drei Gewürze.
So, das wäre einmal getrocknete Minze, da könnt ihr auch frische nehmen, schmeckt auch sehr sehr gut.
Ich hatte jetzt leider keine frische da.
Dann habe ich hier Sumak, Essigbaumgewürz. Schmeckt auch wieder so ein bisschen säuerlich,
sehr sehr lecker, darf auch nicht fehlen
Und dann habe ich hier noch scharfe Paprikaflocken. Ich nehme da jetzt ein bisschen wenig weil
die, die uns kennen, die wissen Hamza und ich, wir sind nicht so - wir können das nicht so mit dem Scharfen.
Aber ich mache den Dip natürlich euch zuliebe! So und jetzt einfach alles miteinander mixen.
(H: Ich mag kein Aca!)
Aca...acı!
(H: *lacht* Acı!)
So, Spritzer Zitronensaft vergessen! Ist zwar nur 'n Spritzer aber der macht viel im Geschmack aus!
So, zum Schluss geben wir das einmal noch durch ein feines Sieb.
Dann darf der Rest abtropfen und der Djp ist fertig!
Und Dip Nummer 3 - mein persönlicher Favorit -
das ist ein Auberginen Dip, den gibt es im Türkischen echt oft aber ich hatte gerade auch mit Hamza
eine Diskussion wo ich ihm auch so ein bisschen Recht geben muss
das gibt es auch im Arabischen, das heißt dann Baba Ghanouch?
(H: Baba Ghanouch!)
Und ich glaube im Türkischen macht man kein Tahina rein, ich bin mir jetzt gerade auch nicht sicher
weil ich das auch von 5 verschiedenen Menschen immer so gezeigt bekommen hab
und ich habe jetzt so meine eigene Variante entwickelt.
Und dafür gebe ich hier einfach ein bisschen Öl, das ist ganz neutrales Öl in meine
- ja, ich habe jetzt hier meine Pizzaform genommen, Hauptsache es ist ofenfest -
ein bisschen verteilen und dann nehmen wir Aubergine. Ich habe hier zwei, die ich jetzt halbiert habe
und die gebe ich jetzt mit der Schnittseite nach unten einfach drauf.
Ofen ist vorgeheizt auf 190° C Ober- und Unterhitze. Jetzt steche ich da so ein bisschen ein
und jetzt werden sie wie gesagt im vorgeheizten Backofen vorgebacken,
ein bisschen weich gebacken für circa 40-45min
und dann ein bisschen auskühlen lassen damit ihr euch nicht die Finger verbrennt.
So, bis gleich ihr Lieben!
Anschließend dann ganz einfach die Haut entfernen und jetzt nehmen wir uns unsere Auberginen
und geben die in Joghurt. Ich hab hier direkt eine Schüssel mit Joghurt, spart ein bisschen Geschirr,
kann ich direkt alles mit rein tun. Hier nehme ich übrigens 3,5%igen, ihr könntet auch 1,5%igen
oder 10%igen nehmen, also bei dem Rezept ist das echt egal.
So, das gebe ich jetzt rein und auch hier wieder das gleiche Prinzip:
alles reinwerfen und dann wird's püriert. ich habe jetzt hier frischen Basilikum.
Bitte immer frischen nehmen, das schmeckt so gut!
Einfach rein. Dann habe ich hier Salz.
Tahina wie ich grad schon erwähnt habe, mit Tahina find ich's persönlich mega lecker!
(H: Du kriegst jetzt so viele Nachrichten dass die sagen: "Nee, Tahina kommt nicht rein!")
Ja bestimmt, ich weiß gar nicht ob's im Original so ist.
(H: Aber normalerweise ist es richtig!)
Ja, ich bin gespannt auf die Diskussion
unter diesem Video weil echt jeder macht das anders!
Dann habe ich hier wieder gutes Olivenöl, mit rein. Und was bei mir auch nicht fehlen darf ist Knoblauch!
Und dann wie gesagt anschließend einfach nur noch pürieren.
Aaaah und -
(H: Was denn?)
Und wieder Spritzer Zitronensaft vergessen zu erwähnen! Und einen Spritzer Zitronensaft rein!
Das könnt ihr auch ganz am Ende machen, da muss auch gar nicht so viel rein.
Ich hab's heute mit meinem Zitronensaft, ne?
(H: Du magst keine Zitrone glaub ich)
Doch, eigentlich schon!
Und fertig ist der Auberginendip! Echt krass wie schnell das geht,
dabei denkt man: "Oh, selbstgemachte Dips dauern immer so lange!" aber es geht sehr schnell
und ich mache wie gesagt immer echt viel mehr als ich an einem Tag benötige
weil ich dann am nächsten Tag davon esse und selbst wenn wir keinen Besuch kriegen,
dann gibt's das einfach zum Frühstück!
Was gibt's besseres? Richtig richtig lecker!
Ich wünsche euch jetzt ganz viel Freude beim Nachmachen,
ich werde euch wie gesagt alle genauen Infos hier unten in die Videobeschreibung aufschreiben,
auch bezüglich Haltbarkeit, Portionen, und und und.
Und ansonsten wünsche ich euch noch einen wunderschönen Tag.
Vergesst nicht meinen Kanal kostenlos zu abonnieren und diesem Video ein Däumchen nach oben zu geben
wenn euch diese Art Rezepte gefallen. Also bis zum nächsten mal auf Kikis Kitchen, Tschüss!